hey this is presto Walker reminding you
to mind your decisions the William
Lowell Putnam mathematical competition
often called the Putnam competition is
an annual exam for undergraduate college
students in the United States and Canada
you have three hours to solve a set of
six problems for an average of 30
minutes per problem and then you have
another three hours to solve another set
of six problems so the test is six hours
long for 12 questions each question is
worth 10 points for a maximum of 120
points the test has legendary difficulty
the average median score is about one
point even though the students taking
the test are highly accomplished no
calculators are allowed on the test and
you have to prove your answers to earn
points the problem in this video is
adapted from the 2004 Putnam exam
problem a 1 first let me present it in
casual language it's about basketball
diandra has been working hard to improve
his free-throws early in the season his
free-throw percentage was below 75% but
by the end of the season his free-throw
percentage was above 75% was there
necessarily a point during the season
where his free-throw percentage exactly
equalled 75% now let me present this in
a little more precise language deandre
keeps track of s of n the number of
successful free throws in the first n
attempts of the season early in the
season s of n was less than 75% of n but
by the end of the season s
of n was more than 75% of n was there
necessarily a point during the season
where s of n was exactly 75% of n while
this problem looks to be quite difficult
this is considered to be one of the
easier problems asked on a Putnam exam
can you figure it out give this problem
a try and when you're ready keep
watching the video for a solution
before I get to the solution I want to
mention a fun fact
DeAndre Jordan improved his free-throw
percentage tremendously from 2015 to
2018
he went from around 45% which is one of
the worst of all time to about 75% which
is nearly league average the lesson is
that hard work and practice can bring
tremendous results this is true in
sports and it's also true in math class
so how do we solve this problem well you
might think the answer is no because
free throw percentages can skip over
values for example let's say you make
one of two free throws your free throw
percentage will be one half or 50% now
let's say you make the next free throw
so you're two of three your free throw
percentage will be 66.6 repeating notice
that your free throw percentage was
below 60% and then above 60% but never
exactly equalled 60% so why would the
case of 75% be any different you might
think that it would be possible to skip
75% but remarkably the answer is you
cannot skip 75% DeAndre's free throw
percentage must equal 75% at some point
because 75% is equal to 3 over 4 why
does it matter that it's equal to 3 over
4 well here's the proof suppose the free
throw percentage never actually equals
75% this is going to be a proof by
contradiction
this means the success rate has to jump
75% between n and its next shot n plus 1
you have to go from below 75% to above
75% so let's put that in a mathematical
equation
first the free-throw percentage will be
below 75% then on the very next shot it
has to be above 75%
we can simplify this a little bit since
the free-throw percentage increases the
shot n plus one has to be a successful
attempt the number of shots made on n
plus one has to be the number of shots
made on n plus one so the numerator
becomes s of n plus one so now we have a
set of two inequalities now we're going
to change 75% into three over four let's
split these two inequalities
now let's cross multiply on each one so
here's what happens on the left-hand
side and here's what happens on the
right-hand side so let's simplify the
right-hand side it's going to simplify
to be 3n is less than 4 multiplied by s
of n plus 1 so notice that 3n is in the
middle so we can now combine these two
inequalities so now we have 4 times s of
n is less than 3 n which is less than 4
times s of n plus 1 but this is
impossible
this inequality means there is an
integer 3n that's in between the
consecutive integers 4 multiplied by s
of n + 4 multiplied by s of n plus 1
it's not possible to have an integer
between two consecutive integers
therefore we reached a contradiction and
so we must have that the free-throw
percentage did exactly equal 75% at some
point now remarkably we could actually
generalize this proof the answer will be
true for any percentage where we have a
fraction K minus 1 all over came the
proof will work very similarly it's
approved by contradiction we suppose
that we never actually equaled that
percentage this means we would have to
jump the percentage between two
consecutive shot attempts so we set up
our inequalities as before and then we
do the same sort of algebra we're going
to cross multiply each one and then
we're going to simplify
then we would have an inequality where
there is an integer that's between two
consecutive integers and that's
impossible therefore we can conclude the
free-throw percentage must have exactly
equaled K minus 1 all over K at some
point so while this problem isn't easy
this is one of the easier problems for
the Putnam exam thanks for watching
these map videos available for free on
YouTube build confidence for students
and inspire mathematical discovery for
viewers around the world they have over
a 100 million views and the channel has
over 1 million subscribers please
subscribe for free to get the newest
videos and email me a map topic or
puzzle pressure and mind your decisions
calm if you so choose you can check my
merchandise on teespring
you can check out my books listed in the
video description and you can support me
on patreon thanks for watching and
thanks for your support